even next to somebody that you performed
with Paul McCartney Is there a
difference uh musically when you're on
stage with a a rock star versus a
country star
a performers and they're all songwriters
and singers and I've I've always you
know thrown out a little rock song in
some of my albums here and there so it's
not that foreign to me but most most of
the rock stars stay up uh late at night
and uh sleep a big part of the day so
I've been working kind of around the
clock on some of these people I've had
that kind of have that system so it
makes me kind of been working around the
clocks when some of the people that you
know kind of keep those different hours
but it's been a joy and it's been a
thrill we've got and then Elton John you
know working with him on his song Don't
Let the Sun Go Down on Me and we've just
got done Fogerty so many wonderful uh
iconic singers and all these wonderful
songs so I'm really anxious for the
public to hear it I think they're going
to enjoy it I know I've loved doing it